this cheesy chicken quesadilla may be
the easiest thing I've made this week it
is packed with flavor and so good let's
get into it first things first once your
chicken breasts have been washed and
dried season with the following spices
and the star of the show is this instant
pot it literally did majority of the
work let's go ahead and get it nice and
hot we're gonna saute some onions some
peppers once it's nice and fragrant
we're gonna add our chicken next add
some chicken stock close it up and
pressure cook for 15 minutes once done
it'll be super tender take it out and
shred it when you come in with your hand
blender and blend everything from there
reintroduce the chicken folks this
instant pot is on sale during this Prime
day act fast this is an essential
kitchen tool next to the large flour
tortilla hit it with some cheese add
your chicken and of course it's our
house extra chicken of course folded up
nice and crispy folks this is it